un labyrinthe niché au coeur de champ de
maïs un joueur Pontchartrain le pop-corn
labyrinthe propose depuis le 8 juillet 5
km de chemin à parcourir en famille ou
entre amis sur une parcelle de 4
hectares on a dessiné 5 km de chemin et
dans lesquels les gens viennent tout au
long de l'été se perdre à l'intérieur du
maïs en tant qu'agriculteur ça me permet
de pouvoir parler un peu de mon métier
des différentes cultures que je fais sur
mon exploitation enfin ça crée un lien
social avec la population autour et
après bah c'est une aussi une
diversification de mon activité inventée
en 2009 dans le Morbihan le concept
c'est peu à peu développé dans d'autres
départements comme ici dans les Yvelines
le premier labyrinthe a ouvert en dans
le 77 il y a 4 ans et du coup nous on
est arrivé il y a trois ans dans cette
franchise énigme ou jeu en bois les
visiteurs ont le choix entre plusieurs
parcours mais le but reste le même
trouver la sortie le plus vite possible
c'est sympa avec les enfants en plus il
y a des jours en bois donc on peut entre
les énigmes les parcours en bois il y en
a pour tout le monde c'est l'idée du
petit ça fait déjà deux fois qu'on vient
au labyrinthe et franchement le parcours
est quand même sympa c'est assez ludique
super un peu casse-tête des nocturnes à
thème sont également organisés le
vendredi et le samedi le labyrinthe est
ouvert tous les jours jusqu'au 3
septembre puis tous les week-ends
jusqu'à la fin septembre